Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa.
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are- It's a day!
We're here for- Together!
Are you nervous?
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
Everybody!
Where was I supposed to say that again, FUWAMOCO-chan?
We're your hosts, all FUWAMOCO related!
BAU BAU!
Mofius!
FUWAMOCO Morning is back!
I love hibernation!
BAU BAU!
How many Ruffians is this your first FUWAMOCO Morning?
Moco-chan's glasses now!
Better to bring the morning one, right?
I see an important question, but what is FUWAMOCO Morning?
I'm glad you asked because I was just about to explain it for those that are joining us for the first time!
Yeah, today we just want to cheer you on.
Well, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short-format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, Monday.
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
It's hosted by us,
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Yes.
Now, let's please tweet your thoughts, maybe right now, with the hashtag.
Hashtag.
FWMCMORNING!
Let's go BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO morning!
BAU BAU!
Thank you Abyss for joining us!
We're back!
FUWAMOCO Morning is back!
Let's make this the best week you know!
BAU BAU!
Well Moco-chan, you know a lot's been going on.
What do we have first today?
Did you want the good news or the bad news, Ruffians?
The good news, you know!
Bass!
X-Bowl!
Big announcement!
Bad news!
Good news!
Bad news first!
You're getting the bad news first.
That's what I'm asking for, Moco-chan.
I saw good news.
You're getting the bad news.
Well, Moco-chan.
It's been a while.
We had a good run.
But... There's been another Pero Sighting.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, are you okay?
Did you have a bad sleep?
Was the pillow really hard or something?
The hibernation wasn't so great.
It's a waste of a hibernation.
Well, Moco-chan, let's see where Pero was spotted.
Well, we have... De-den!
Wait, what?
What?
Pero's looking... Eggs are fluffy now.
Maybe the hibernation, you know, kicked in and sort of bundled up.
Yeah, I'm not so tooty, but... It seems like he was pretty nasty to you there, hey?
You know, if he's nasty, we nasty him back!
Got it?
Maybe the color of the scarf on him?
It does sort of look pretty nice.
It does.
Especially with the leaves, you know, they sort of blend together.
Yeah, but... But you know, it's such a nice scarf, you know?
Maybe... Stylish, nasty, yeah.
Maybe you could wear it instead, or... You know, we would love to wear that scarf, right, Moco-chan?
Yeah!
Oh, right.
I think we'd appreciate it more than him.
Oh, you think you know?
Oh, the scarf is gonna make him fly better if you kick him!
Maybe.
I don't know if aerodynamics works that way, but you can always give it a try, Ruffian!
It's sort of frightful though, you know?
Before.
2D now.
That's what hibernation does to Pero, huh?
Got really sort of big.
Ruffians even though I know we're talking about aerodynamics and everything, but it's good that you're so kind and gentle, right?
Giving Pero a scarf when he really doesn't need it.
You should just take it for yourself and rip it off.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
You know, it's been a little while since the last FUWAMOCO Morning.
But now, we're back!
FUWAMOCO Morning is back!
Official!
FUWAMOCO, we didn't go anywhere, you know.
And maybe there's some Ruffians that are like, huh?
Huh?
What's this hibernation?
I didn't hear about this.
Well, FUWAMOCO Morning back in the end of... The beginning?
The beginning of October?
The end of October, two weeks ago.
Yeah.
It went on hibernation so that FUWAMOCO, you know, that we could focus on, you know, all the exciting things that we've done within the past few months!
And we realized maybe there's some Ruffians that are like, I missed it.
Oh, well, I was kind of busy.
I had some hibernation duties for myself.
Yeah.
We thought we'd bring you up to speed what's been going on in the world of FUWAMOCO and a little bit of hololive as well.
This is what we remember right now.
It might be incomplete.
It'll be filled up.
Let us know what we're missing, FUWAMOCO Ruffians!
Since the last FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning episode 140!
Well, to start off the series of good news, there's some really horrible news.
FUWAMOCO's favorite place in the world, Akihabara MisDo, closed after 52 years.
Yeah.
Happy Flashback Day!
Bye!
Wow!
You know, now it's not just hololive device.
There's also new kouhai device, Flow Glow!
You know, we got some new kouhai and they're ready to do some rapping.
Stylish rap.
And then FUWAMOCO, you know, Ruffians!
Thanks to you, FUWAMOCO somehow, we are named VTuber of the Year for 2024.
BAU BAU!
And then, FUWAMOCO, we also got a 3D Christmas event along with the other numbers of our English.
Reindeer.
Snowman.
Santa.
Um, there was also a little bit of a bittersweet departure saying goodbye to Fauna-senpai.
But we report all the news.
Report all the news, yeah.
But, uh, well, I did.
I was crowned the king of Janken in hololive.
Yes!
So that's pretty impressive, okay?
Yeah, I'm pretty lucky!
You feel like the luck is still following you?
I do, actually.
I really do.
There was a time recently that I was like, this is because I'm super lucky this year.
It hasn't ended, Ruffians.
That's why, oh... That's how the keys flew off the keyboard, because we were lucky.
Yeah.
It comes and goes.
I'm the strongest of Rock, Paper, Scissors and all of us!
Advent!
We got brand new outfits!
Casual outfits!
Out in a boat!
That's us!
You know, so today, you know, I really want to put my casual dress down for the Ruffians.
Do you know that that's the official name of these outfits for us?
For FUWAMOCO.
It's our out in a boat outfit.
Yeah, out in a boat outfit.
You know that FUWAMOCO fans didn't know.
FUWAMOCO fashion fans.
And also big news!
We had our very first birthday live!
Our first mini birthday concert!
We worked so so hard!
We know we sung with our senpai!
We danced together with Advent too!
So if you haven't checked out our birthday concert... It's not a request, it's a need.
And if you already checked it out, then you gotta check it out again.
More news!
FUWAMOCO!
We sent Biboo to the Shadow Realm in Yu-Gi-Oh!
Possibly the most important news out of all of us.
You know what?
When we did an official tournament!
Yeah!
Yu-Gi-Oh Masters!
And we sent Biboo to the Shadow Realm somehow.
I'm not too sure.
Yeah.
Thanks to the Ruffians.
And the Heart of the Cards.
And the Heart of the Cards, yeah.
And then most recently, as in, well, yesterday?
Two days ago?
Depends on your time zone.
Wow!
hololive Expo!
hololive...
That's it.
That was a pretty good rundown.
Pretty good.
I'm glad.
Very late.
Yeah.
Of course there's a lot of other things.
Valentine's, Christmas, of course!
There's a new hololive Minecraft server.
Yes!
New hololive Minecraft server also is out as well!
Very important one.
Yeah.
FUWAMOCO Morning will have more amazing things to share soon with you!
So we hope that you join us for FUWAMOCO Morning on Fridays, Wednesdays and Mondays right here on L2!
BAU BAU!
And for more exciting updates!
Oh wow!
Ruffians!
Like we mentioned, it was actually the 5th, 6th, 5th weekend!
6th Fest at FUWAMOCO!
We had our first ever Fest Appearance!
Color Rise Harmony!
At FUWAMOCO we appeared on Day 1 Stage 1!
Our debut stage together with all of Advent!
At FUWAMOCO!
Of course we performed our original song "Born to be "BAU"DOL☆★"!
And Ruffians shook the entire venue!
All of Makuhari Messe with your big bau bau's and your cola's.
You can feel it in your body, in your bones.
It's just reverberating.
Yeah, I'm a heck yeah.
Heck yeah!
Yattaiga!
But not just BAU, we also have a song!
Yakko no Hugo!
It's an anime song from the anime Super U!
It's a really really special song to us, a song that we've always struggled with singing.
There's lots of harmonies, cool choreography, and the lyrics really really resonate with us too!
Yeah, and maybe there's a high kick.
That was much higher than it was ever supposed to be.
Very much fueled by adrenaline.
And very sore the next day.
But!
We also got all together with all of Advent.
And I think we started a fire.
Because we saw rebellion.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
Ruffians, if you haven't been able to catch up on all the exciting things that happen at SixFest, please head over to SBW and Spawn.
You can get your streaming tickets right now.
There's an archive and it'll be available for one month.
So please check it out while you can.
A very, very special debut stage at best.
And of course, we're also part of the
What is it?
Rensai-kyoku?
Yeah, the group songs as well.
And then, on day two, we are part of the creator stage.
We performed together with Nenechi, her song.
Girafa Nenechi's Giragira Family.
Girafa!
It's a very cute, very silly song, very jumpy song.
So we hope that you'll also check that out as well if you haven't.
It was a lot of fun!
Being able to hear your BAU BAUs, see your panelists, see your smiles, and maybe a few tears here and there, Ruffians!
It meant the world to us!
Thank you so much!
We also had a very silly and maybe too energetic MV with Koyori-senpai!
So please don't miss it!
You know, if you're curious about FES, you've never seen FES, but you don't really know, there is a free sneak peek as well on the official hololive JP channel, so please check it out!
You need to check it out, there's some amazing performances there!
Yeah, but if you want to see FUWAMOCO, we definitely recommend Stage 1!
Get your stream ticket or camera free!
BAU BAU!
Comment in a box?
That's a sight to be seen.
BAU BAU!
And not only was it Fes, but it was also Expo!
The big hololive Expo!
Super Expo!
Expo is a little bit different from Fes.
Fes is where, you know, you go on singing, the dancing, the concert.
Expo is the convention part where you have a bunch of fun things to do.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
We were not expecting that at all.
We were not expecting them!
Yeah!
You know we got the first flip set, FUWAMOCO Arnando words, which are in production right now!
They're cute!
Aren't they cute?
Aren
Ruffians!
I made it brighter for you.
It's a production.
Moco-chan took the photo, so don't blame me.
It was a group effort.
Yeah, just like everything else.
Yeah!
You adopted us!
BAU BAU!
And not only was our nendor is there, but also!
De-den!
BAU BAU PUPPY!
Yeah!
It's over!
BAU BAU!
These aren't finished either, there's no color rule.
But!
They're in production.
Look at Moco-chan's tummy!
Oh my gosh.
I guess.
Moco-chan, you realize once I get my paws on these, I'm gonna have to touch this Moco-chan's tummy and then touch the real tummy.
I'm just saying it is a figure so I can't look pretty closely, huh?
But you can't touch, right Moco-chan?
How else are you going to pick up the figures?
I'm from the base, you know.
Don't touch the lights.
When you pick up a figure, you grab it by the leg and go, what?
What kind of way are you picking up figures, Moco-chan?
Huh?
Normal way.
But please look forward to the dolphins just like the nendoroids.
They are in production.
You cannot adopt them yet, but prepare to adopt them.
Maybe some.
BAU BAU.
But you know, I think Ruffians, I think from your reactions, you kind of like figures, right?
Right.
Well, we have good news.
We have good news because hololive English -Advent-, we're having a pop-up shop!
It's gonna be starting from April 25th at the Shibuya Tsutaya.
It's right at Shibuya Scramble.
Right at the famous Shibuya Scramble, we're gonna be having a very special pop-up shop just for Advent.
And it was also announced FUWAMOCO.
There's gonna be brand new FUWAMOCO figures one size and scale with an original, a brand original outfit.
There's a catch, something's a little bit different.
What kind of outfits is the brand original?
What brand is this?
I don't... Have you seen?
Maybe you can check it out.
What kind of outfit could it be?
Bead outfits?
I know there's bathing suits, bikinis.
Bathing suits before.
You know it is in Shibuya, right?
I know.
Shibuya fashion.
Goodbye wallet.
Hi Ruffians.
Maybe, you know, maybe you'll find a new wallet at this pop-up shop, right?
Maybe, who knows what they could have!
I have a feeling that wallet might be pretty empty and it might do a good job at even emptying your existing wallet.
I'm sorry!
BAU BAU!
This is how things work, though.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Enjoy hololive songs in THE FIRST OFFICIAL MOBILE GAME!
That's exactly what it says.
It has to be here with that project called DREAMS!
Just like that movie!
And look, it's gonna be a simultaneous worldwide release!
It's available in some regions.
That's what it says!
What kind of game is it?
A mobile game?
That's what we do know.
We do not know much about it.
Enjoy hololive songs in official mobile games.
That's what we know.
But FUWAMOCO we know a little bit more.
Moco-chan!
You had some fun playing.
I did.
I did have a little bit of fun.
And I thought it was very fun.
And you're laughing pretty hard too, huh?
Laughing pretty hard!
Apparently I'm pretty good at it.
Yeah, you got praised, huh?
I did.
So please look forward to it, Ruffians!
It's gonna be so much fun!
So much excitement!
It's a game, and it's pretty fun.
Enjoy the hololive songs in a mobile game.
BAU BAU!
This game is gonna go big!
It's exciting!
Let's have a lot of fun with the mofians!
You played it!
I thought you didn't.
But you know, at FUWAMOCO we are hololive and it's a hololive game.
Mobile game to be more accurate.
Official mobile game to be most accurate!
Can you say the title again?
Project Code 3.
That's how it goes.
I want to know if that's the title, but... Right!
Right!
For now, that's what we're gonna call it.
But please look forward to it, Ruffians, and make sure that you have lots of fun playing it once it comes out to PVDs.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, you know it.
Do we have a picture for this?
For what?
Well, FUWAMOCO, you know, X-Bowl, everybody had a bunch of fun around the venue.
FUWAMOCO, we got to go to X-Bowl a little bit early.
We are unleashed with some pens.
And we got to climb all over the place.
The floor, the walls, almost anything and everything.
Fuwawa also did something a little bit embarrassing.
Uh, you know, um, FUWAMOCO, sometimes things happen, and, um, Moco-chan, kind of, you went on ahead without me.
Why do you make it sound like I did something wrong?
You did!
You went on ahead without me!
And then I couldn't find Moco-chan!
So I was running around looking for Moco-chan, when MOCO-CHAAAAN!
I'm reverberating around the hall.
And... Well, I don't realize it until it's too late, but... I ran past YAGOO-san!
And... You know, YAGOO-san sure was gonna be like, Oh!
Oh, it's nice to see you, Fuwawa!
But you left.
But I didn't see him.
I snubbed him.
I snubbed YAGOO-san.
Yeah.
But I found Moco-chan!
I should've just made her go back on her own.
I was dying!
Did you say good morning?
Say hi to YAGOOo-san!
I ran back with her.
We apologized and said OHAYO GOZAIMASU!
And then we ran off.
But YAGOOo-san was nice and we also got YAGOOo-san to sign our FUWAMOCO edible posters too!
We should maybe post a photo, right?
We have a lot of photos to post.
FUWAMOCO Signature, yes!
I guarantee you there's probably no other FUWAMOCO because it's signed by YAGOO-san.
Only one's in existence!
FUWAMOCO!
Thank you YAGOO-san!
I'm sure YAGOO-san wasn't gone.
I'm FUWAMOCO Shiori.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
FUWAMOCO Morning!
We're back with lots of exciting things!
What's FUWAMOCO-chan?
You made a sound that was kind of voice on there.
You know...
Ruffians!
It happened again for the first time in forever, but it happened again!
There's a misunderstanding, Ruffians.
I don't know how I'm going to tell this to you, but... You know, FUWAMOCO Morning is back after the hibernation period.
Yeah!
And well... I think you're mistaken.
You're misunderstood.
Because FUWAMOCO Morning... We have not been gone for six months.
Yeah.
You know how long it's been?
When was the last episode?
It's been just a little bit.
Four months, exactly.
Four months.
Four months!
It's not six months!
It's not seven months!
It's not 84 years!
Not ten months!
It's only one third of the year!
It hasn't been a half.
Yeah.
Right.
It feels like it's been an eternity.
I know.
Right.
When we said it was going on hibernation...
Hibernation over then.
And here we are again!
Ready to start...
Day off on the right paw three times a week.
FUWAMOCO is back!
We didn't go anywhere!
We're just here now in the mornings together with your love fans.
Not in this time zone.
We're around in every time zone.
If you stay up late or wake up early enough.
Exactly!
BAU BAU!
No misunderstandings, okay?
It hasn't been that long.
What a good tears, Ruffians!
We're back now.
No more time for tears.
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO!
Let's check out some of our regular corners!
Starting with our Doggie of the Day.
Let's check out see who our Doggie of the Day today is.
Our Doggie of the Day is... De-den!
Today's Doggie of the Day is Cream!
Cream, what a baby!
Those ears!
So cute, it's like a plush.
Cream is a new addition to the family and is going to become the best buddy for the other doggy, Coffee!
Coffee!
Coffee and Cream!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I need another addition to the family now.
Who?
Cookie.
What about Sugar?
Coffee, Cream and Cookie!
What about Sugar, Moco-chan?
You may also need another one.
Tea?
Sugar?
No, no tea or you have coffee!
So in case you wanted more dogs, here's more names we've got.
Next is Cookie, and then Sugar.
What about Biscuit?
No, you've got Cookie!
Unless you like biscuits more than I do.
Either or.
But you know, Cream is still a little bit of a little tiny puppy here, but I'm still a coffee and cream dog.
Perfect together in real time.
Yeah, perfect pair.
FUWAMOCO-chan, how does Cream bow-bow?
I think so, I think that's exactly it.
I can hear Cream speaking to me.
Yeah, that's exactly how Cream sounds, FUWAMOCO-chan.
Yeah, well, you know, I think we can see here Cream, Cream still isn't quite sure of things, you know.
That makes sense.
A lot of new things going on, but that's okay because Cream's a cute baby.
I will grow big and strong soon.
You know what you do as a baby.
Put on bright red lipstick.
And then you go MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA MWA
Let's take a look!
Where did we go last?
We have... De-den!
Cherry blossoms!
Pink like Moco-chan!
She's such a bright pink!
Am I blooming?
The blue sky!
Very FUWAMOCO season!
FUWAMOCO season!
Are you blooming Moco-chan?
Am I blooming?
Ruffians, what do you think?
I'm always blooming!
Yes!
BAU BAU!
But you know, spring is here, and so is FUWAMOCO Morning!
Out of hibernation now.
Forget about the snow after stage 2.
But you know, everything's starting to warm up, so I think it's just about the perfect time for some more walks, right Ruffians?
Time to go on a walk soon!
Make sure you go and check out just what has changed during this hibernation period, you know?
BAU BAU!
Thank you for sharing your world with us!
And for the Question of the Day!
Today's Question of the Day is... Dango!
Oh simple.
Simple like dango.
Dango.
BAU BAU.
What is dango?
Dango is a type of Japanese perfection.
Sweet!
Usually dango is like a sweet rice ball.
But, you know, a dango, that's mochi, right?
No, dango and mochi are different.
You know, you make dango with shiratamako and mochiko.
But it's mainly not mochiko, so it's more like a thicker, more ball-like consistency.
Firmness to it.
Made firm.
And there's different type of dango.
There's mitarashi dango, which is like a sweet soy sauce sauce you put on top.
And then there's sanshoku dango, which is the emoji that you can see right now!
Yeah, the hanami dango!
There's three colors.
You know, they all taste the same.
The pink, the white, and the green.
Lots of different types.
But the question, Moco-chan!
The question, Moco-chan!
Do you like them?
Yeah.
Simple.
And you know it's almost the time for lots of dango eating because it's springtime.
Saishoku dango is good.
Kusa dango.
Definitely kusa dango!
What's your favorite dango?
I think I really like mitarashi dango.
I think so too.
I like sanshoku dango, but I like mitarashi dango.
The sweet soy sauce is just, it's so salty but also very sweet.
Yeah, it's yummy.
And then you know, Fuwawa, I'm actually pretty good at making dango.
So nice.
Sometimes.
Sometimes it's a big mistake.
Sometimes it's just horrible.
But you know that one time I was really good.
One time?
Which means I'm pretty good at it.
Yeah.
That one time.
And you know, speaking of that!
Just, you know, the other day Gura-senpai did a dance!
She sang the song Daam Go Daai Kajoku from Twonaga!
BAU BAU!
Thank you for all of your submissions!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
That's okay, use the hashtag.
But you know, send us your vlogs, your burning questions!
Answer them, you know!
We don't really have too many of them often, right?
And also don't forget as well!
We have FUWAMOCO scoop, so if you think there's something you would like to see us cover, please let us know!
But Ruffian, also if you happen to see Pero, maybe it's best if you let us know.
That was Pero Sighting.
And then we can inform all the other Ruffians too.
But most importantly, use the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
BAU BAU!
I'm so happy to have FUWAMOCO waiting back now!
It doesn't feel like any time has gone by.
Ruffians, let's get our next stream!
Another stream coming up!
On a schedule!
On Tuesday the 11th, we're gonna be having an extra special HoloEN 6 Fest After Party Karaoke!
All for FUWAMC BAU BAU!
It's gonna be here on our channel!
I don't know if a lot of Ruffians really noticed it.
FUWAMOCO Morning you can count on one hand.
Please join us!
Will it be archived?
It will be archived!
Please join us for FWF!
I'm super excited.
And on the rest of our schedule, we have more FUWAMOCO Mornings!
And on Friday, which is technically White Day, we're gonna be releasing a very special song cover!
It's been quite a while since our last song cover release, so we hope that you'll be there to listen to it.
I'm really nervous about this one.
We're really nervous so please join us for it, okay?
And then after that we'll be having a release after party.
We'll be talking about why we chose it, the process, etc.
And then on the 16th as well, on the Sunday, we're gonna be having a mini horror game festival.
Playing a bunch of horror games that look kind of spooky and different.
Maybe a little bit silly.
So we hope you'll join that for us, Ruffians!
Who knows how long it will be in enduring.
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
Ruffians joining us in the archive today too!
Your FUWAMOCO word is... BAU BAU!
We're back!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Thank you Ruffians for joining us today!
Also, FUWAMOCO Morning!
But!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Red Jump!
BAU BAU!
Darkest Tauba!
Tech Channel!
BAU BAU!
Kurodeku!
Mofukoro!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!